♪♪
Partnering with Apple Music, we
found three amazing scouts,
to search the world for country
musicians, who don't necessarily
fit the mold.
I'm gonna take one mark.
-(Click)
(Click)
♪♪
Mickey Guyton:
They say country music is three
chords and the truth.
It's singing about life and your
life story.
Jimmie Allen: It's a
worship song to blue
collar,
9 to 5 people.
Orville Peck:
There's definitely no singular
way to define country music,
but, in my mind, country is
defined by storytelling.
Jimmie Allen:  -Yeah.
You've seen country music one
way for so long, and now
we're finding it from all over
the world.
My artists, I love all four of
them.
Jimmie Allen:
Justin.
Camille.
Jimmie Allen:
Dhruv.
And Ale.
My four artists are...
Orville Peck:
Alisha.
Micaela.
Orville Peck:
Ismay.
And The Congo Cowboys.
And last, but certainly not
least,
Mickey Guyton:
Ashlie Amber.
Wandile.
Mickey Guyton:
The Betsies.
And Chuck Adams.
Woo!
Orville Peck:
I really love helping artists
with advice that
we had find to out the hard and
long way. (Laughs)
-The what way?
(Laughs)
Jimmie!
-(Laughs)
♪♪
Country music was the first kind
of music I ever heard.
Cause' my dad uh, loves country
music.
-Remember the little
cassettes and the little tapes,
you know?
Where you go and, go to the
radio and try and record your
songs.
-I initially wanted to do pop,
cause that's where I saw a lot
of women who
Camille:
were successful, that looked
like me.
Camille:
But every time I would record a
song, it would come out so twangy.
My friends, they were like,
listen girl, these are great,
but you're a country artist.
♪♪
Viewers can look forward to the
development of these artists.
We are getting to work with
Ashlie Amber:
the most "Boss" people in the
industry.
Mickey Guyton:
Jemel McWilliams,
an amazing creative director.
Orville Peck:
Production Designer, Natacha
Aubier-Hatch.
The legendary, the music
director. Mr. Adam Blackstone.
Woo!
It's gonna be life-changing.
♪♪
Reese Witherspoon:
It's time to show the world
you're artists in country music
Reese Witherspoon:
and you belong here.
Kacey Musgraves:
It doesn't matter if you're from
India or Japan or Mexico.
Kacey Musgraves:
You deserve to tell your story,
and if it comes out country,
awesome.